You guys, last night we had
our big show in Puerto Rico.
And I'm happy to report the
island is open for business,
while our government
still is not.
That's right.
The federal government
has been closed for 26 days,
and experts say the shutdown
could cause the economy
to shrink.
Then the President said,
"No, it's only shrinking
'cause it's cold outside."
[ Laughter ]
Well, today,
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi said
that due to the shutdown,
Trump should postpone
his State of the Union address
or do it in writing.
Which explains why Trump
just asked Twitter
to raise the character limit
to 50,000 words.
[ Laughter and applause ]
A lot of people are calling
Pelosi's decision
a real power move.
Even Vladimir Putin was like,
"Damn. She is not here
to make friends."
[ Applause ]
But despite the shutdown,
the FDA is trying to restart
their inspections
of risky foods,
though so far
it's just one guy going,
"Does this smell bad to you?
Try it. Drink it."
And the CEO of Delta said
the shutdown has already cost
the airline $25 million.
He's not that worried,
because they'll make it all back
if two people pay
to check their bags, so...
"We're back!
-"Come on. We're back.
-We're back, baby!"
-Come on!"
-But Trump's been upset
with how the media
has covered the shutdown.
And this week, he tweeted
that the fake news
needed to "chill."
Yeah, well, here's what
three different news networks
were covering at the
exact same time this morning.
Let's see if any of them took
Trump's advice about chilling.
-All of these tributaries
are going to come rolling
into the same place --
Russia, Mueller,
stuff we don't even know about.
-The damage
being done to the economy
is worse than they predicted.
-But you can make a snowman
feminine or masculine.
You have the ability.
-But you don't want to hurt
the feelings of the snowwoman.
-Right. I mean, you could make
a separate snowwoman.
[ Laughter ]
-Seemed pretty chill,
those last people.
As I mentioned, last night,
we had our Puerto Rico show,
but that meant we missed
something pretty incredible
that happened in the news.
I'm talking about
President Trump buying fast food
for the Clemson football team.
and sending a tweet that said
he ordered "1,000 hamberders."
[ Laughter ]
Hamberders.
Hamberders sounds like
how you would say "hamburgers"
if your mouth
was full of hamburgers.
"Hamberder.
I need a hamberder."
[ Applause ]
Later, Trump told Secret Service
to keep an eye out
for the Hamberdergler.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-Well, people have been saying
that Trump has been bored
during the shutdown
and spending a lot of time
looking out windows.
You know, until one of his
staffers finally tapped him
on the shoulder and said,
"Sir, that's a microwave."
[ Laughter ]
"It's filthy outside."
Trump has been complaining
about being stuck inside
the White House
during the shutdown.
He's actually been so bored,
he started writing a book
about his experience.
I think he might have been
inspired by Dr. Seuss.
Check this out.
It starts, "The sun did not
shine, I did nothing at all.
All alone in the White House,
cause they won't build my wall.
[ Laughter ]
I just sat there on Twitter
refreshing fake news
and said how I wish
I had something to do.
They won't give me my slats
or concrete or steel girders.
So I guess I'll stay home
and eat all the hamberders."
[ Laughter ]
He's onto something.
-Wow. He's onto
something, right?
-Here's another big story.
Confirmation hearings are
under way for Trump's pick
for attorney general,
William Barr.
There he is.
Looks like Peter Griffin from
"Family Guy" with a law degree.
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news.
The first trailer for the new
Spider-Man movie just came out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And it's already causing
a lot of excitement.
In this movie, Peter Parker
flies to Europe
for a school trip.
Check out the trailer.
-Planning a trip?
-Mm-hmm. Going to Europe.
It's a school trip.
-Get your passport?
-Peter Parker here to
pick up a passport, please.
-Mini toothpaste?
-Mm-hmm.
-Pack your suit.
-TSA security is closed
due to the government shutdown.
All flights are canceled.
-What just happened?
"Spider-Man: Staying Home."
-"Staying Home."
-Wow.
[ Applause ]
-Well, here's a local story.
Yesterday the old
Tappan Zee Bridge
was demolished
with a controlled explosion.
And a lot of people
stood around for hours
to watch the big moment live.
Well, it happened pretty fast.
Listen to what one guy shouted
on TV right after.
-All four right here of the
shots that we have of this.
We got you -- Oh.
-There it goes!
-There it is.
-Oh, I missed it!
[ Laughter ]
-That guy's wife was like,
"You just had to go get
a hot dog, didn't you?"
Ah. That poor guy has no luck.
I guess he's a cameraman.
Check out what happened to him
when they blew up
the Georgia Dome.
-Really?
-Got a bus, dude!
A bus!
Geez! Get out of the way, bus!
[ Laughter ]
Ugh!
-Can you imagine that?
[ Laughs ]
And finally, listen to this.
China just made history
by growing the first plant
on the Moon.
When asked what type of plant
it is, China's astronaut said...
[Inhales sharply]
"Don't worry about it."
We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots!